it's time to open up my apple phone
answer some q a and we'll get this uh
show on the road cool what do you think
i i dig it i wanna while you'd pull that
up i'm gonna shoot some questions here
from the
peanut gallery for adam sosnick uh this
one's from noah i found interesting my
roommate is a pig
is it worth an extra 150 a month to get
my own place and not have to deal with
this
oh hell yeah dude yes 150 that's the
only difference bro i will give you 150
yeah right i think it's worth it at some
point you do need to do i love that
you're doing the numbers i love that
you're asking the question who was this
this uh his name is it just says noah
noah good for you noah i don't know how
old noah is at some point you need like
at some point the roommate thing's gotta
go
at certain point you should have a
roommate because if rent is two thousand
bucks and you're splitting it a thousand
a thousand yeah you're saving a thousand
bucks a month at 12 grand a year
but if the difference is
850 to a thousand just go live on your
own yeah just do it dude i'm saying if
that's the difference
but if being a slob saves me 12 grand a
year and i can save 12 grand and i do
that for two years three years and i
save 30 freaking grand
boom i never have to deal with sloppy
roommate ever again in my life totally
long-term perspective versus short-term
perspective and the price and the other
david in the chat he goes uh is
quote-unquote saving and quote-unquote
investing
synonymous after you have six to 12
months of expenses saved so saving and
investing synonymous
after you have six to 12 months of
expenses saved are they synonymous yes
so if you're investing are you in the
same way
saving
again it's all about risk it's all about
it's all about risk in return i love
having cash on hand
cash
gives allows you opportunities cash
gives you comfort
okay so whatever your comfort number is
so for for a while for me dude
i felt
i don't know why it was
i felt so secure having a hundred
thousand dollars in the bank that was my
number yeah i won't have a hundred
thousand dollars in cash
and then when i have that i'll invest
what's left and then someone's like dude
what do you why do you need a hundred
grand in cash what are you doing with it
and eventually i've said oh look all
right six months
okay
that's you know 30 grand that's the
number i need to have whatever the
number is okay cool that's my comfort
zone invest it
investing is long term investing is
three five years minimal
minimum
okay
cash is
is money you're gonna need the next few
years yeah understand that so the more
money that you're able to invest like
you're not gonna save your way to
becoming a millionaire no one's like i'm
saving every day and becoming a
millionaire eventually you're gonna have
to invest
because saving doesn't give you that
compound interest right investing does
excuse me but it wasn't our homie uh the
doctor that retired at 41 yeah
didn't didn't you she did that she saved
it to be a million like a
retired oh she said she was maxing out
all her retirement accounts oh that's
right excuse me 401k or four through b
or roth ira excuse me excuse me yes nice
try david yikes no we're gum we got
fabian perez i think this one might be
for me manchester united or liverpool
who wins manchester united has a great
team liverpool right now is undefeated
so i'm going to go liverpool on that one
up the chelsea blue is the color next
question for adam sauce yes let's go
down the um
the chat here i'll um shout out to you
guys if you go onto my instagram
saucetalksmoneysostalksmoney on
instagram i do q a
uh every thursday i pull it up right
here i haven't read anything a lot of
these questions came while we've been
live and i just see the first thing that
comes to mind and i answer your
questions yeah eventually we're going to
be doing live
call-ins eventually
david when we're making that's when are
we making that big switch to the new
format adam you tell me tell me no no to
like the new not the sling stuff oh
when's that happening
uh tbd tbd pbd tv let's get some
questions here um all right let's see um
okay so
i'm nick colb says do you use debit or
credit cards i use credit card and i pay
it off in full every single month i've
got a dope credit card and you don't use
all sorts of funds use your credit card
i i i always have a couple hundred bucks
cash people think i'm crazy i have cash
i love having cash i love having a
couple hundred bucks cash with me hey
congratulations a tip hey you know you
pay for this um but i don't use my debit
card to pay for i like if i go to the
store if i go
to a bar if i go to a restaurant credit
card yeah but 100 every single time like
not not 99 of the time 100 of the time i
pay my credit card off in full every
single month it's usually a couple grand
in full every single month zero percent
of the time am i late on the payment or
not making the full payment so every
time your your credit card goes up a
couple grand and at the end of the month
it's always back at zero yes
sick every time um
i was gonna ask you something yes oh not
gonna
they're carrying cash yes uh as someone
who loses his wallet oh uh quite a bit
do you i i am known for that ask sam
people around the office i lose my
wallet i wouldn't keep cash i wouldn't
keep cash well i would or keep cash in
that you dude be so goddamn hyper aware
of that gut i don't know i've lost 300
before okay i lost my wallet and for for
someone like you that just kind of
getting going three hundred dollars will
piss
dude it was three hundred dollars in
college yeah
that's that's grounds for right now it's
like ugh back then it was like look
david you gotta find the root of the
problem not the symptom the symptom is
that uh all right i lost a couple bucks
again the route why do you always lose
your wallet
i have no idea okay so i find i find
that uh
a lot of the um
like i i like you know i respect paul's
creative mind and he also loses a lot so
maybe it's something in the creative
realm
how about you get creative and figure
out how to get creative
yeah get really creative and keep your
wallet
um okay
let's see what else we got here what
point you're designing
chad rad says at what point should you
decide to cash in your bitcoin for
dollars
again are you a long-term investor or
you are a day trader i don't know
so it also depends on where'd you get in
on did you buy bitcoin at 50 and now
it's at 60 or did you buy it at 10. yeah
and now it's at 60. that's on you but
investing is long-term
um
i don't have the answer i don't think
anybody has the answer of what's going
to happen with bitcoin do you believe in
the asset class keep it yeah if i had
bought bitcoin when it was 10 bucks and
i had a thousand of it right now
cash the [ __ ] you're cashing out i'm
cashing out if you need the cash or you
can cash out some of it not all of it
um okay you're right
i'm
impulsive okay so um that was chad
mustafa says i have almost 5k saved
in february i want to buy a bike
a bike max for 4k
i plan to save like 800 bucks a month
can i afford it
um you're gonna
you save five and you're gonna spend
four on a bike
um
and i plan to say
i don't know bro that's something that
how bad do you want this bike i i don't
know it's like if you said you had 10
grand 20 grand i'd say go get the bike
but if you're gonna deplete 80 of your
savings go buy a bike
doesn't seem like the best decision save
that money um let's talk nfts and crypto
today nfts we covered in the last
podcast if you didn't see that go back
to the last podcast nfts i said that i'm
not gonna miss the boat on nfts not that
i'm a huge believer in it but i'm not
gonna be dismissing and i had some the
concept that's you did
roddy says what's coming for the economy
i don't know robert kiyosaki says it's
going to crash other people think that
it's going to it's going to be stable i
don't know but
uh
the paranoid always win stay paranoid um
save that money
um
can you please do a crypto only special
no i'm not gonna do a full bitcoin
crypto special however i will interview
some crypto experts coming very soon so
be a separate interview
with crypto experts coming very soon
um
says thank you so much for doing this i
feel sad for those who are missing this
thank you we appreciate you we
appreciate you for tuning in we want to
answer your questions um
that was from hemath himanth also says
um
what should a person in their 20s be
doing
productively understand i say this all
the time if you're 20 you're going to be
25 if you're 25 you're going to be 30 if
you're 30 you're going to be 40.
have a long-term vision for yourself
have a game plan of where you want to be
with your life you can think short-term
day-to-day with your money got to go to
job go to work got to do what i got to
do but steve jobs it up think about
where you want to be in five years where
you want to be in 10 years you can do
both short term
in the short term this is what i need to
do long term this is where i'm going if
you don't know where you want to end up
you don't know where you're going how
are you going to make a plan to get
there right um
[Music]
a lot of crypto stuff a lot of crypto
stuff all right last couple questions
then we're done here last couple
questions filling in the dead air matteo
says why saving on a 401 k really yeah
david matteo there you go why saving on
a 401k when i can invest now on real
estate and have a better roi
okay
number one i don't know why you're
guaranteeing you're gonna have a better
um
roi with real estate typically the stock
market performs better than the real
estate for sure you just got sauced you
just got soused typically stock market s
p 500 10 um
uh annual returns over a year typically
your real estate your house mortgage
payment typically is returning three
percent a year obviously you can make a
good purchase and all that
um again full disclosure not a big real
estate mortgage guy
i like freedom i like flexibility i like
keeping my overhead low i like saving
that money so i can invest in the stock
market and assets that appreciate over
time uh time for one my last question
boom
uh will the us dollar crash lol or will
the fed stop arguing about it and print
more money i hope they do not print any
more money i don't know if like look
it's all speculative all i don't know
what's going to happen to the entire u.s
economy this i mean this wholeheartedly
i don't know what's going to happen in
the economy i don't know if they're
going to print more money i don't know
about inflation the one thing you can
control is your own money yeah how much
money you earn how much money you keep
how much money you spend how much money
you save how much money you invest
there's only two ways
to have more money
spend less or make more that's it
all we talk
is money if you enjoyed that short clip
from the sauce cast click here to watch
another click here to watch the full
episode or just stay broken